wait I want to go back to your dating so
I've got a few times and he's like oh
like maybe people take a picture of me
here and you're like whatevs
but you still are into him um I I
couldn't really tell that if I was into
him because I think our first date was
only like 45 minutes or an hour long we
just had coffee mm-hmm and I knew that
he had just woken up because it was 2:00
p.m. but his eyes were just full of
crust I know Jesus how are you different
your date yeah
that's early from well you know it's
great though I guess is that he's
totally not putting on any previous
there's no front so there's no sir when
I when you finally got into it pretty
seriously there was no deviation from
the original person that I write that's
Carly still a mess he lived like you
know when I first came to his house
finally this place didn't have furniture
it was just a big giant pile of shoes
like you had to climb over to get to the
room and that's not even an exaggeration
yeah I'm hoarder yeah and then I know
the man for like not like how long were
you always like I don't care or does
that something I was - bro listen to me
right now man I'm listening I'm telling
you right now man I was born like I
don't give a [ __ ]
really right I didn't know how to pay
taxes but four dates I'm saying four
days for anything you were all you
listen to me man you think that like
being the way I look I was killing it in
the 90s was I wasn't because imagine
this look at this body
yeah you didn't have this body right
okay you didn't have you know your why
you got to make it like that I don't do
anything I mean that's what I'm thinking
but you don't have what I mean what I
have I think that you're wrong because I
don't care what you I know but you're
not gonna believe this but I sincerely
from the get-go found you - found you
attractive all right I mean Corian funny
yeah she's like in high school I would
have dated dude no you wouldn't did
[ __ ] good morning crystal meth you
didn't ugly oh yeah I [ __ ] a lot of
ugly guys cuz I wasn't that cute either
when I first came from the Philippines I
had a photo you [ __ ] back then
choose to gum ratio it was I was a mess
who else could I could have the best
part of that statement I was like of
course I would've dated you I dated
other ugly guys that's what I'm saying
so but wait a minute nobody feel like
now though but like do you feel like now
do you feel the wave of like Asian
sensation like Asian right what do you
think don't you see it well I have to
admit and I and you know I see also just
fans don't take a photo of like an Asian
magazine with 15 Asian stars yeah and go
how come you're not in it there's one
with you know BD Wong jo koy bunch of
people like you know like doing a Vanity
Fair pose yeah and these are the leading
Asians in Hollywood why not why not say
why aren't you in it because they want
you to be in it I know but the thing is
is that it makes me feel like [ __ ]
because then I read and I go yeah why I
am and that remember the other day I'm
like how come I'm not in this but isn't
that kind of nice that those fans liked
you so much that they're like you should
be in or the hundred most influential
that was it right there was a hundred
most influential Asians in Hollywood the
top hundred I can't even make the top
hundred not even the top hundred right
that's depressing it's to press Q right
that's exactly why I'm depressed joke
boys in it right no he wasn't in the top
what but you know how he's guy Lee
wasn't a tough under yeah boy found
interesting about that Korean magazine
with all the Koreans in the front it was
all Koreans but then jo koy he was like
well that's right okay who isn't okay
yeah you know it's my theory you know
wait you grew up in the Philippines yeah
what hell were you when you came over 15
oh my god and then straight to Long
Beach pasta do you know when to you know
how game do you know that Pasadena was
listen did you know that Pasadena right
he is gangland I didn't know that until
a few years ago somebody but you believe
that yes they have a definitely not
you're going to the Ice House right
right when you drive there think colors
no here's the thing only thing I've
known about Pasadena yeah is the ice
house so for years I've been like this
is obviously the best neighborhood
lesson film but then if you actually
talk to people from passing they're like
yeah but don't go to I forget what
summit mountains
it's on summit and mountain and I've
been on Colorado Street and they have
great sushi joints and really you want
to test these fools don't call all
gangbangers are watching this [ __ ] is
Bobby Lee's the one talking [ __ ] not Tom
no Tom told me that like [ __ ] passing
what you said no they said they're not
[ __ ] real gang members a week I said
I don't you said he said I'm Korean
you said I'm happy I'll [ __ ] a [ __ ]
gang member in the bar you'd now most
Asians as you know are really good at
the martial art which is your favorite
like of those okay now we're getting to
it now
we're getting to the nitty-gritty of it
all just stop no you asked the question
and the answer you throw the stars what
is it I'm Korean
so with delicious is enough i quando
exactly yeah I took that one day when I
was a kid yeah master Hong Kong Kim was
really a doctor
a fatty were the in [ __ ] tackle don't
care no he was a you know you yes I was
now actually I was pretty skinny little
kid at that age
[Music]